[Musik]
am Ende ist genau das eingetreten was
viele befürchtet haben auf dem 20
Nationalkongress der Kommunistischen
Partei Chinas haben die Delegierten
Shisha Ping wiedergewählt Shisha Bank
historische dritte Amtszeit als Chinas
Staatschef es handelt sich um ein
Ereignis mit großem Einfluss auf die
internationale Politik diktatorische
champign hat es nicht nur geschafft
weitere 5 Jahre an der Macht zu bleiben
nein er hat auch die absolute Kontrolle
über sein Land erlangt an den Hebeln der
Macht im staatlich China sitzen jetzt
seine tollsten gefühlsleute Vertreter
anderer Fraktion der Kappe Chinas wurden
abgesetzt oder haben einfach nichts mehr
zu melden das vielleicht beste Beispiel
dafür ist der Ständige Ausschuss des
Politik Büros der Partei die bekannte
Gruppe der 67 aus 7 der 25 Mitgliedes
Politbüros zusammen es ist das zentrale
Gremium das die Kommunistische Partei
führt und damit quasi ganz China leitet
von den sieben Sitzen des vorherigen
Kongresses hat schief viele neue besetzt
nur drei Mitglieder sind geblieben diese
drei sind sie selbst und zwei emojale
parteiade und neu hinzugekommen sind
vier weiter e die ebenfalls Ski treu
ergeben sind die gewisse Pluralität der
verschiedenen Fraktionen innerhalb der
chinesischen Regierung gehört nun
endgültig der Geschichte an
[Musik]
Ski nicht liebsame Spitzenfunktionäre
wie Wang Yang und Lieke Yang wurden
entfernt dabei waren gerade sie zwei
wichtige Vertreter der Touren bei
Fraktion der sogenannten Jugendliga der
Partei dies ist eine Fraktion der auch
der ehemalige Präsident husin Tower
angehört und die sich nicht besonders
gut mit Shisha Pinks eigener Fraktion
versteht der letzte Kongress der
Kommunistischen Partei Chinas also
nichts als eine große politische
säuberungs- und Gleichschaltung Aktion
Gewinner dieser Aktion war eine neue
große Fraktion der Partei die neben der
Turn Pie und der Shanghai Bande
umschanze Mini existiert die Rede ist
natürlich von der neu gegründeten
ski-bande
[Musik]
und der Arzt sicher was das alles
bedeutet in den nächsten fünf Jahren
wird niemand absolute niemand in den
Schatten stellen
von nun an Wörter chinesische Führer
mehr Macht haben als je zuvor deshalb
nennen viele schon jetzt den neuen Mao
aber über diese ganze Geschichte über
die Fraktion der Kommunistischen Partei
Chinas und wie es geschafft hat die
volle Kontrolle über die Partei zu
übernehmen haben wir bereits auf
visualpolitik berichtet ich werde euch
das betreffende Video verlinken wenn ihr
solltet es unbedingt gesehen haben im
heutigen Video wollen wir viel mehr
Bilanz ziehen über den Mann der jetzt in
China so mächtig ist wie nie zuvor was
waren Pings größte Erfolge und größte
Misserfolge in den letzten 10 Jahren an
der Spitze Chinas und ich vielleicht
wichtigste Frage von allen hat die
bisherige Ärsche überhaupt dazu
beigetragen dass China eine super macht
geworden ist oder ging es ihm immer nur
darum seine eigene Macht zu maximieren
und so zementieren auch auf Kosten des
Landes selbst genau das wollen wir heute
ganz genau unter die Lupe nehmen und
bevor wir dies tun nehmen wir noch ein
anderes nicht minder großes Problem
unter die Lupe die Passwortsicherheit in
Unternehmen nein leider noch viel zu oft
und friedlich vernachlässigt das Thema
dabei liegt die Lösung ganz nah sie
heißt not past Business und ist der
Sponsor unseres heutigen Videos hast du
jemals darüber nachgedacht wie viel Zeit
du mit der Suche dem erraten oder dem
Zurücksetzen von Passwörtern verbringst
nun laut einer Studie verlieren
Mitarbeiter jährlich 11 Stunden damit
was für größere Organisation eine
Produktivitätsverlust in Millionenhöhe
bedeuten kann mit nordpass Business
lösen sich diese Probleme und unnötigen
Kosten jedoch in Luft auf die
Anmeldedaten aller Mitarbeiter werden an
einem sicheren Ort gespeichern können
per Klick abgerufen werden bist du es
leid auf Zugänge zu bestimmten Konten zu
warten wenn die Hauptkonto Inhaber krank
sind oder in Urlaub mit nordpass
Business funktioniert das Teil von Konto
zu seinem nahtlos und unterbricht deine
Arbeit nicht und was ist mit
Zahlungsinformation musstest du auch
schon stundenlang auf den Zugang zur
Firmenkreditkarte warten oder die
Buchhaltung vor jedem Onlinekauf anrufen
mit nordpass kannst du diese Information
einfach sicher und in Echtzeit mit dein
Team Kollegen teilen und die
Aktualisierung unterstützensibler Daten
ist mit nordpass Business ebenso einfach
vertraulich Informationen können sicher
an einem Ort gespeichert weil wir davon
anderen abgerufen oder aktualisiert
werden viel Spaß Business erleichtert
aber auch die Arbeit von Administratoren
neuen Mitarbeiter der nur wenigen
Augenblicken Zugänge zu Systemen und
Software gewähren diese wieder entziehen
wenn Sie das Unternehmen verlassen mit
notbass Business ist dies ein
Kinderspiel aber das ist noch nicht
alles schließlich bietet nordpass
Business auch einen der robustesten
Sicherheitsscanner und datenverletzung
und liegt frühzeitig zu erkennen mit der
Hilfe von nordpass oder langjährigen
Erfahrung die in dieser Lösung steckt
kannst du viele gefährliche Szenarien
von vornherein vermeiden und ich dann
auf wesentliche konzentrieren also geht
diesen wichtigen Schritt macht dein Chef
oder eure it auf nordpass bis es
aufmerksam oder teste es einfach selbst
ganz unverbindlich und kostenlos für 3
Monate mit Hilfe des promo codes oder
des Links in der Videobeschreibung also
worauf wartest du noch ebenfalls ganz
unverbindlich und freiwillig wenn auch
nicht kostenlos ist die Möglichkeit
unsere Arbeit hier bei visualpolitik
finanziell zu unterstützen wie immer
sind für euch für jede Hilfe dankbar den
Spenden Link hierzu findet ihr ebenfalls
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video so
und nun lasst uns wieder zu unserer
großen Preisfrage kommen hat die
bisherige irische pingu beigetragen dass
China eine super macht geworden ist oder
ging es ihm immer nur darum seine eigene
Macht zu maximieren und zu zementieren
auch auf Kosten des Landes selbst
aufgepasst
[Musik]
die Erfüllung chinesischer Träume
beginnen wir mit den Erfolgen ja die
gibt es obwohl China Unterschied wieder
viel autoritärer regiert wird als früher
aber viele Erfolge sind wahrlich
Interpretationssache meist handelt es
sich um Erfolge aus der Sicht der
pekingerführung der erste ist die
angebliche Beseitigung der extremen
Armut als 2012 an die Macht kam schätzte
man das etwa 82 Millionen Chinesen
extrem arm waren also etwa so viel wie
die gesamte Bevölkerung Deutschlands im
Jahr 2021 schließen wir jedoch auf
Schlagzeilen wie diese Chinas Ski
erklärt Sieg über die extreme Armut auf
den ersten Blick eine äußerst gute
Nachricht nicht wahr nun diese erste
scheint trügt und schnell kehrt
Ernüchterung ein wenn man ein wenig
hinter die Kulissen blickt dann bei
jeder handelt es sich eben um eine
Diktatur und alle Diktaturen lieben es
nun mal sich ihre eigenen Erfolge herbei
zu fabulieren und zu Recht zu biegen
natürlich will dies auch für
demokratische Regierung aber den Staaten
mit einer normalen Opposition und freien
unabhängigen und staatsfernen Presse
kommen sie damit nicht zu leicht durch
im Falle Chinas muss man nämlich nur
eine Einkommen von etwas mehr als 620 $
im Jahr haben um der Stadt Statistik der
extremen Armut zu entkommen
aber abgesehen von diesen kleinen
Statistik Tricks ist in den ersten zehn
Jahren von Pinks Herrschaft das
Einkommen der Chinesen tatsächlich
weiter angestiegen so stieg das
durchschnittliche verfügbare Einkommen
pro städtischen Haushalt zwischen 2013
und 2020 um gut zwei Drittel bei den
ländlichen Haushalten hat es sich mit
einem Anstieg um rund 82% weniger als 10
Jahren fast verdoppelt tatsächlich ist
die Verbesserung der Lebensbedingungen
im ländlichen China eines der Hauptziel
des chinesischen Führers seit er
Präsident des Landes ist vielleicht hat
das etwas damit zu tun das als
Jugendlicher selbst erlebt hat was es
heißt im ländlichen China anzusehen
[Musik]
die provokante Frage ist jedoch traten
diese Veränderungen nicht dank schießt
sondern trotz schieein schließlich
übernahm er von seinem Vorgänger den er
auf dem letzten Parteikongress brutal
demütigen ließ einen gut bestelltes Haus
die Trends waren bei seiner
Amtsübernahme eigentlich schon
vorgezeichnet aber zur Wirtschaft und
den Schulden kommen wir noch später wenn
es um die Misserfolge des neuen großen
Führers geht lasst uns jetzt noch ein
wenig bei den Erfolgsgeschichten auf den
ersten Blick bleiben denn viele Dinge
sehen zunächst einmal wie Erfolge aus
bis das dicke Ende kommt Deutschland war
ja auch lange Zeit von Angela Merkels
Politik begeistert genau wie diese hat
sie nämlich auch ein Gespür für populäre
Themen die zunächst einmal super klingen
so z.B
Infrastrukturausbau Chinas Ski drängt
auf einen umfassenden Ausbau der
Infrastruktur zu Ankurbelung des
Wachstums Skin war und ist besessen
davon das ganze Land mit aller Art von
Infrastruktur zu überziehen ja geradezu
zu fluten ein Grund er muss einer
wirtschaftsschwung geben die immer
langsam Thema wächst drücken wir es mal
so aus aus Sicht der chinesischen
Regierung ist der bloße Bau von Straßen
Schienen Brücken und Wolkenkratzer der
beste Weg um das Wirtschaftswachstum
anzukurbeln und tausende von
Arbeitsplätzen zu schaffen
als die große Finanzkrise 2008 ausbrach
legte die chinesische Regierung wie wild
neue Bauprojekte jegliche Art auf vor
allem Straßen und Schienen und das
Ergebnis kann sich wahrlich sehen lassen
unterschieding ist die Zahl der
Kilometer ein Hochgeschwindigkeit
Zugverbindungen um 330% gestiegen auf
über 40.000 km kein anderes Land der
Welt kommt auch nur annähernd an diese
Zahl Herren ein anderes Beispiel sind 82
9 Flughäfen die seit 2008 in ganz China
gebaut worden
china hat sich gewaltig verändert und
den neuen Häuser Straßen und Schienen
kommt vielen Menschen zugute ob sich das
alles aber auch wirtschaftlich gelohnt
hat dazu kommen wir später ein
Erfolgsprojekt bei dem Einfluss noch
größer war ist das Weltraumprogramm
in den vergangenen zehn Jahren hat China
eine beachtliches Stück zu den beiden
großen weltraummächten USA und Russland
aufgeholt so ist es dem Land gelungen
astrom mobile zum Mond und zum Mast zu
schicken das ist wahrlich ein großer
technologischer Schritt nach vorne China
ist erst die zweite Nation in der
Geschichte die einen Rover auf dem Mars
landet china macht eine historische
Landung auf der dunkle Seite des Mondes
das chinesische Raumschiff ist das erste
das jemals auf diesem und erforschten
Gebiet gelandet ist eines der großen
Versprechen ist nämlich dass China den
Traum vom Weltraum verwirklichen wird
man will bis zum Jahr 2045 der große
Spitzenreiter in der Raumfahrt sein
natürlich vor den Vereinigten Staaten
und dafür liegt sie ordentlich Geld auf
den Tisch erhöhte das Budget der sie NSA
der chinesischen NASA auf fast 10
Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr damit liegt
sie zwar immer noch weit hinter der Nase
zurück aber nicht mehr so viel wenn wir
die Unterschiede in den Personalkosten
berücksichtigen
[Musik]
ob man wirklich zu den USA aufschließen
wird ist nicht vorher zu sehen aber
immerhin hatte es China danke übrigens
Investition geschafft im Jahr 2020
seinen eigenen navigationsdienst in Alt
vollständig zu installieren und zwar
auch für die zivile Nutzung damit sind
die Chinesen nicht mehr auf das
amerikanische GPS angewiesen und nicht
nur das china baut auch seine erste
permanente Raumstation
es besteht also kein Zweifel das
chinesische Raumfahrtprogramm hat durch
die shamping einen großen Schub erhalten
und von der Raumfahrt ist es nicht weit
zum Militär auch das hat unter Ski
großen Auftrieb erhalten und seine
Aufrüstung ist aus chinesischer Sicht
eine riesen erfolg.ping hat quasi
höchstpersönlich eine umfassende Reform
der Streitkräfte und des nationalen
Sicherheitsapparats vorangetrieben und
das ging so ähnlich vonstatten wie die
Machtübernahme in der KP er hat Leute
die ihm gegenüber loyal sind in die
Zentrale Militärkommission gesetzt denn
was im Militär passiert sollte künftig
im Sinne schief sein naja es ist
natürlich nicht so ungewöhnlich für
Diktatoren dass sie das Militär auch
kontrollieren wollen nicht dass da mal
einen General auf dumme Ideen kommt ihr
wisst schon was ich meine doch die Armee
Reform betrifft nicht nur die Anbindung
ein schießen sondern auch eine
tatsächliche technologische
Modernisierung China Streitkräfte waren
vor seinem Amtsantritt völlig veraltet
und sie hatte sich vorgenommen sie auf
den neuesten Stand zu bringen
[Musik]
so zum Beispiel durch eine Strategie
Zivil militärischer Fusion die zielt
darauf ab China so schnell wie möglich
ein technologisch fortschrittliches
Militär zu verschaffen das bedeutete für
chinesische Technologieunternehmen
sowohl für die zivilensektor als auch
immer fürs Militär zu forschen und zu
produzieren und es bedeutet jegliche
importierte Technologie im Land auch auf
dem militärische Nutzung zu überprüfen
und tatsächlich auch dort zu verwenden
es erklärt natürlich warum die USA und
viele andere Länder des bestens die auch
so viele technologischen
fortschrittliche Produkte nach China
beschränken
wie ihr sicher wisst sind moderne Armeen
meist kleiner was auch an China zu sehen
ist 2015 wurde die Verkleinerung der
Armee um 300.000 Mann angekündigt das
entscheidende Kriterium ist heute nicht
mehr die Mannstärke sondern der Grad der
technischen Modernisierung die Qualität
der Ausbildung das belegen ja
schließlich auch die horrenden
russischen Verluste bei ihrem Krieg in
der Ukraine Peking weiß das und hat
deswegen auch das Zusammenwirken
zwischen den verschiedenen
Teilstreitkräften stark verbessert denn
wenn die Invasion Taiwans gelingen soll
müssen Marine Luftwaffe und her optimal
zusammenkämpfen können und sich nicht
gegenseitig bekämpfen wie putinslaken
viele Militärexperten glauben dass China
Streitkräfte heute viel leistungsfähiger
und einsatzfähiger sind als noch vor 10
Jahren und das wäre ohne Penis Reformen
nicht möglich gewesen
allerdings stellt sich die Frage
inwieweit Chinas Armee wirklich fit ist
für einen waschechten Krieg einen
ausgedehnten knallharten und komplexen
militärischen Konflikt denn bei allen
Verbesserungen der letzten Jahre Zweifel
Experten ihre tatsächliche Kampfkraft
meines echter Einsatzerfahrungen stark
an Manöver sind eine feine Sache aber
wirklich erfahrene Führungskräfte ob
Generäle Offiziere oder Unteroffiziere
werden nur in der Praxis geboren und
hier hat die sogenannte
Volksbefreiungsarmee Chinas mangels
geeigneter Auslandseinsätze null
Erfahrung vorzuweisen sie steht quasi
mit blankem Hintern da niemand weißt du
wirklich ob es sich nicht um eine reine
Parade Armee handelt setzt sie nicht
dieser prall in Bezug auf die Sicherheit
zumindest die eigene Sicherheit auch
noch mit einem anderen Erfolg und zwar
mit der Gründung der nationalen
Sicherheitskommission der
Kommunistischen Partei Chinas im
November 2013 einer Kommission die
welche Überraschung von selbst geleitet
wird diese Kommission ist im
Wesentlichen dafür zuständig die
Kontrolle der Partei über nationale
Sicherheit und die Außenpolitik zu
stärken es geht dort aber auch über
wirtschaftliche soziale und kulturelle
Angelegenheiten man könnte sagen
schießpartei will alles steuern was auch
immer in China passiert Kontrolle und
Ideologie überall wenn die wichtigste
Konsequenz dieses neuen Gremiums ist das
direkt und ohne jegliche Einmischung
entsch wird was genau eine Bedrohung für
die nationale Sicherheit ist und was vom
staatlichen Repressionsapparat verfolgt
und bestraft werden muss aber vielleicht
fragt ihr euch an dieser Stelle warum
das in aller Welt eine Leistung
darstellt nun wir reden von einem
Diktator der seine Macht festigt und aus
seiner Sicht ist der Zugriff auf alles
im Land ein großer Erfolg außerdem ist
derzeit niemand absehbar dem dieses
gewaltige Machtinstrument abnehmen kann
um einen genau so einseitigen Erfolg
handelt es sich bei der Übernahme
Hongkongs der ehemaligen britischen
Kolonie
[Musik]
was bis dahin eine der freisten Städte
der Welt war steht nun unter der
vollständigen Kontrolle der sogenannten
Kommunistischen Partei China ist dies
bedeutet nicht nur einen wichtigen Musik
für sie bringt nationalistischen Kurs es
ist auch das Ende ist vielleicht
wichtigsten Zentrums einer chinesischen
Opposition und der Kritik am Regime
und ob wir als westliche Beobachter
diese Erfolge nun mögen oder nicht es
sind diese fünf Errungenschaften die
erschießenping erlauben vor seinem
eigenen Volk gut darzustellen denn
zugegeben so viele Repressionen und
diese Zentralisierung der Macht werden
dem Land langfristig wohl schaden aber
was soll's das wichtigste für Ski war
mit diesen Erfolgen in den 20 Kongress
der Partei zu gehen und wiedergewählt zu
werden und genau das hat er geschafft
allerdings ist das nicht die ganze
Geschichte denn neben diesen relativen
erfolgen und politischen Siegen gibt es
auch sechs große Misserfolge und diese
Misserfolge könnten schießt dritte
Amtszeit sehr sehr schwierig machen also
schnallt euch an es geht los
[Musik]
die Rasse im Imperium
natürlich können wir nicht über große
Misserfolge sprechen ohne Kobe zu
thematisieren lange Zeit hatte ich
chinesische Regierung ihr Management der
Pandemie als Erfolg verkauft der geniale
Führer Ski könnte das Virus in Schach
halten so dass narrativ aber im Laufe
der Zeit wurde klar dass die Realität
vollkommen anders aussieht
[Musik]
die radikale Null kubit-politik hat das
Land und seine Wirtschaft gelähmt und
weitgehend vom Rest der Welt abgekoppelt
natürlich kann man sagen dass ich gerade
während der corona-pandemie so gut wie
alle Regierungen einen mehr oder weniger
unfreiwilligen Wettbewerb geliefert
haben ihren Bürgern in den Fuß zu
schießen die Wirtschaft und die
Gesundheitssysteme zu schädigen und
Grundrechte mit Füßen zu treten schieß
regime-sätze dieser global
gespenstischen evil Clown Fiesta die
durch die absolute Krone auf seine Anti
corona-strategie war ein wahrhaft
sagenhafter Misserfolg die chinesische
Führung hat es nicht geschafft die
Gesellschaft immun gegen das Virus zu
machen ganz im Gegenteil die Strategie
aus knallharten lockdowns hat das
Problem auf Dauer aufrecht erhalten
selbst drei Jahre nach Ausbruch der
Pandemie setzt man weitgehend lernen
resistent noch immer auf massive
Einschränkungen und umfassend
restriktive nicht medizinische Maßnahmen
während diese im Westen ja zum Glück
weitgehend wieder verschwunden waren
natürlich geht auch hier die
Aufarbeitung der vielen Fehler nur
Schlitten voran und wird in vielen
Fällen wohl im Sande kaufen von
personellen Konsequenzen ganz zu
schweigen aber die Probleme werden
wenigstens öffentlich thematisiert so
für den nächste Pandemie und so Ski
jedoch hat es tatsächlich geschafft in
China ein System zu formen das
tatsächlich in der Lage ist jedes uns
bekannte Maß an Inkompetenz Ignoranz und
Heuchelei noch mal weit zu übertreffen
der Grund liegt natürlich in
schießkultur der Gleichschaltung und des
kontrollwahns die Parteikader und
Beamten vor Ort haben große Angst davor
bestraft zu werden wenn Sie
selbstständig Entscheidungen treffen
oder die Vorgaben aus Peking nicht
erfüllen deswegen setzen Sie lieber
einfach nur technokratisch und
oberigkeitshörig zugleich das
zentralistische Micromanagement schieß
um ohne Rücksicht auf die lokale
Bevölkerung und Wirtschaft hierzu hat
sie natürlich überall seine ja sage und
Speichel lecker installiert und diese
haben wiederum ähnliche Charaktere unter
sich installiert bis in die kleinsten
Winkel des Landes Kompetenz wurde
erbarmungslos ausgemacht das einzige was
zählt ist die Loyalität zum großen
Führer damit hat sich Ski im Falle von
Corona jedoch selbst in eine sind alle
manövriert man kann eine derart komplexe
Angelegenheit wie eine währungs-epidemie
noch dazu in einem derart riesigen Land
wie China nicht zentralistisch Steuern
ein einziger Mann kann einfach nicht
über die Kapazitäten verfügen die
Situation im ganzen Land entsprechend
differenziert zu analysieren die
richtigen Schlüsse daraus zu ziehen und
dann an die jeweiligen Umstände
angepasste Maßnahmen zu leiten hier
stößt die zentralistische auf einen Mann
ausgerichtete Diktatur ohne Opposition
kritische Presse Gewaltenteilung und
ausgewogene kontroll- und
Steuerungsmechanismen eben an ihrer
natürlichen Grenzen und deswegen ging es
dann irgendwann im letzten Winter
einfach nicht mehr weiter die Zahl der
fehlanalysen und Fehlentscheidungen war
zu groß geworden der daraus erwachsene
Volkszorn und die Wirtschaftskrise waren
zu einem existenziellen Problem der
Partei selbst geworden ehrlich Vollzug
man also die Kehrtwende und öffnete das
Land als sei nichts gewesen die bis
dahin verfehlte nun kobit Politik zeigt
aber nach wie vor drastische Folgen man
hat keine einigermaßen funktionierenden
Impfstoffe aus dem Westen zugelassen das
hätte ja das Ansehen schieß als Anti
corona-krisenman beschädigt die Folge
das Virus traf auf eine kaum
immunisierte Bevölkerung und die
knallharten lockdowns hatten denselben
Effekt eine natürliche Immunisierung
konnte kaum stattfinden weder gegen Co
wird noch gegen alle anderen saisonalen
Arten bics Erkrankungen china hat im
Prinzip die Pandemie bei sich im Land
nur verzögert die dicke Rechnung kamen
dann aber im Winter als alle die Faxen
dicke hatten und das Gesundheitssystem
war dann erst recht hoffnungslos
überlastet man kann kaum mit den zählen
der Opfer hinterher oder verschwieg die
Zahlen nach alter kommunistischer
Tradition Liebe ganz in dezember 2022
offenbar 248 Millionen Infektionen China
stellt Veröffentlichung täglicher
coronazahlen ein Kliniken und
Krematorien sind überfüllt die Behörden
kommen nicht mehr hinterher jetzt ändert
die nationale Gesundheitskommission die
Informationspolitik
die verfehlte kobit Politik schießen in
Pinks beschleunigte noch mal die
Wirtschaftskrise in der sich sein Land
befindet das Wirtschaftswachstum in
China ist eingebrochen und die
Arbeitslosigkeit unter jungen Menschen
steigt so stark an dass viel
Universitätsstudenten ist vorziehen ihr
Studium nicht zu beenden denn sie haben
Angst keinen Job zu finden und
arbeitslos zu werden tatsächlich ist die
schlechte Wirtschaftsleistung eine
weitere große Bürde für sie seit er an
der Macht ist sind sowohl das Wachstum
als auch die Dynamik der chinesischen
Wirtschaft zurückgegangen und das obwohl
die Regierung war nicht gigantische
Anstrengungen unternommen hat damit sich
die Dinge anders entwickeln und an
dieser Stelle kommt wieder zurück auf
die Infrastruktur von der ich vorhin
gesprochen habe denn die vielen neuen
Schienen Straßen und Brücken sind nur
ein Erfolg mit Halbwertszeit die
Wahrheit ist nämlich dass die Behörden
extrem viel Geld für Bauprojekte
ausgegeben haben die nicht wirklich
gebraucht werden und dadurch natürlich
überhaupt nicht produktiv sind ganz im
Gegenteil sie verursachen nur eine Menge
laufender Instandhaltungskosten und
diese bringen außer das BIP noch eine
Weile weiter zu beschuldigen gar nichts
das Ganze eher Sinn es wuch sich die
ganze Zeit von ganz oben runter bis auf
die lokalen Ebenen er ist in China
nämlich systemisch bedingt durch
vollkommene verfehlte Anreize in dieser
Grafik seht ihr wie sich das
Wirtschaftswachstum entwickelt hat und
auch die sogenannte
investitionswachstumsquote diese
Kennzahl sagt uns wie viele zusätzliche
Investitionen nötig sind um die
heimische Produktion zu steigern je
höher der Wert umso mehr Geld braucht es
um produktiv zu sein es bedeutet aber
auch je höher der Wert umso weniger
effizient wurde Kapital eingesetzt wie
ihr sehen könnt steigt diese Quote seit
2008 unaufhörlich an während schieß
Amtszeit hat sie sich praktisch
verdoppelt mit anderen Worten es wird
immer mehr investiert aber die
Produktion steigt kaum noch diese viel
Entwicklung liegt daran dass ich
chinesischen Investitionen sehr
unproduktiv sind erinnert ihr euch noch
an all die Hochgeschwindigkeit zu
strecken und Autobahnen die wir bereits
erwähnt haben nun diese Strecken sind
nicht ausgelastet und es gibt unzählige
halbfertige oder gar fertige Häuser ja
ganze Geisterstädte in den niemand wohnt
und auch niemand jemals wohnen wird sie
hat es nicht geschafft diese gigantische
viel Allokation zu verhindern nein er
feuerte sie auch noch an und das
Ergebnis ist nicht nur ein Schuldenberg
sondern ein ganzes Gebirge von
Schuldenbergen und all diesen
Schuldenbergen steht keine adäquater
wirtschaftlicher Benefeld und damit auch
keine Perspektive auf Amortisation und
Rückzahlung gegenüber setzt euch an
denn vergesst nicht es spielt keine
Rolle ob es sich um einen
sozialistisches Land ein Unternehmen
oder eine Familie handelt Geld wächst
nicht auf Bäumen alle öffentlichen oder
privaten Ausgaben müssen auf die ein
oder andere Weise finanziert werden sie
müssen sich rentieren denn wenn man in
Projekte investiert die keine Rendite
abwerfen geht man als Unternehmen pleite
und als Regierung oder Staat nun dann
wächst eben der Schuldenberg und die
Zeche Zahl dann das ganze Volk aber das
ist ein Thema für ein eigenes Video so
weit so schlecht jetzt werden jedoch
einige einwenden moment mal wenn wir uns
die offiziellen Statistik über die
chinesische Staatsverschuldung ansehen
scheint die Dinge doch unter Kontrolle
zu sein da ist nichts dramatisches zu
erkennen ja da habt ihr vollkommen recht
das Problem ist aber dafür über ein Land
sprechen das in Sachen Buchhaltung auf
so manchen blassende locken dreht denn
die tatsächlichen Schulden werden hinter
professionell frisierten Zahlen
verschleiert wir haben einmal ein
Hintergrund wie du darüber gedreht dass
ich euch verlinken werde es ist wirklich
sehenswert schaut euch also anschließend
unbedingt gut an wenn euch interessiert
wie die Fälschung von Wirtschaftsdaten
in China systemisch verankert ist
kleiner Spoiler auch hier geht es um
viel geleitete Anreize als wir das Video
damals herausgebracht haben war dies
eine recht neue Enthüllung mittlerweile
hat es sich aber weltweit
herumgesprochen zumindest in den
Wirtschaftsmedien Chinas
Staatsunternehmen haben den größten
Schuldenberg der Welt angehäuft die
öffentlichen Investitionen in die
Infrastruktur sind eine gigantische
Schuldenblase aber jetzt haltet euch
fest es handelt sich nicht um die
einzige und auch nicht um die schlimmste
Blase Chinas wie wir euch hier auf
visualpolitik schon einmal gesagt haben
verspricht die Immobilienkrise viel
schlimmer zu werden
[Musik]
hat sich in China eine riesige
Immobilienblase gebildet wenn Sie Platz
bedroht das Banken in ihrer Existenz und
sämtliche Ersparnisse in China na ja
zumindest die Ersparnisse von Gemeinden
wie auch die Gelder vieler Familien und
Bürger Chinas Immobilienkrise führt zu
Rekordschulden der Bank of East Asia
fast 9% der Kredite der Bank of East
Asia an chinesische Bauträger waren zum
30 Juni wahrscheinlich wertgemindert das
übertrifft die großen chinesischen
Konkurrenten um drei bis sechs Prozent
schützen zur Folge gibt es heute in ganz
China mehr als 120 Millionen Lehre
Wohnungen das sind alles investitionen
die sich nicht rentiert haben es handelt
sich um Immobilien und Baukredite die
nicht abbezahlt werden können da die
Regierung die Investitionsmöglichkeiten
ihre Bürger einschränkt und in China
Immobilien als scheinbar sichere
Anlageform sowieso maßlos überwertet
sind ist es gerade zu einem Volkssport
geworden sich eine zweite dritte oder
vierte Wohnung zuzulegen egal wo und
egal ob jemand bereit sein wird dort
einzuziehen und dafür Miete zu zahlen es
handelt sich um ein gigantisches und 50
Billionen Dollar schweres globalsystem
wahrscheinlich das größte der Welt zum
Vergleich das offizielle BIP Chinas
beträgt rund 18 Billionen Dollar wobei
diese Zahl wiederum durch die eben
erwähnte immobilienblasenwirtschaft
aufgebläht ist dies alles ist nicht nur
eine unglaublich großes Risiko für die
ganze Volkswirtschaft ja die Welt
sondern auch eine unverantwortliche
Verschwendung von Ressourcen die meisten
eigentümerhofen zwar noch immer es würde
sich irgendwann ein noch dümmerer finden
der einem die shop-immobilie zu einem
noch höheren Preis abkauft wiederum in
der Hoffnung sie einem noch dünneren
später noch teurer zu verkaufen aber die
Zahl dieser Gelegenheiten geht immer
weiter zurück das Kuriose daran ist das
ist in China eigentlich gar keinen
legalen Immobilienbesitz gibt es handelt
sich ja theoretisch noch immer um ein
kommunistisches Land das
Eigentumswohnungen ist also eigentlich
nur eine Pacht gegenüber dem Staat und
wenn diese ausläuft bleibt er
letztendlich auf den ganzen ungenutzten
und verrottenden Bauten sitzen die
kommenden zusammengeschrumpften
Generationen dürfen sich schon mal
freuen und das ist noch nicht das Ende
der Geschichte die chinesische Regierung
hat unterschiedliche Kontrolle der
Kommunistischen Partei über chinesische
Unternehmen Immen s verstärkt was will
man auch erwarten wenn eine Partei alles
kontrollieren will das Ergebnis der
öffentliche Sektor wächst weiter und der
private Sektor sieht allmählich dahin
schaut euch mal das folgende an
[Musik]
und wenn man bedenkt wie schlecht ist um
Produktivität und Effizienz im
öffentlichen Sektor Chinas bestellt ist
heißt das nichts Gutes die Investoren
auf den internationalen Finanzmärkten
wissen bereits wieder haseläuft Chinas
reichste Tai Kunst verloren mehr als
fünf und 30 Milliarden Dollar beim
Ausverkauf an der Börse nach skigeblings
Macht Zuwachs in der chinesischen
Regierung
auf den niedrigsten Stand seit fast 15
Jahren da Investoren aus Angst
dramatischen Schritt seine Macht zu
festigen aus chinesischen
Vermögenswerten flohen aber lasst uns
nicht nur über die Wirtschaft sprechen
dafür haben wir schließlich ja auch
visualökonomik unseren Kanal für
Wirtschaftsthemen dort haben wir erst
kürzlich ein Video darüber
veröffentlicht warum immer mehr
Unternehmen China den Rücken kehren und
welche Konsequenzen dies für die
Weltwirtschaft hat also schaut mal weil
wir so alle konnomic rein wenn ihr
besser über Wirtschaft Bescheid wissen
wollt als die meisten unserer Politiker
schließlich überwiegen auch in der
internationalen Politik Chinas die
Fehlschläge die Erfolge
[Musik]
Pekings aggressive Politik und
Kriegsrhetorik hat so offenkundig
schlechten Ergebnissen geführt so ist es
China zum Beispiel nicht einmal gelungen
Südkorea davon zu überzeugen auf den
US-amerikanischen Raketen Abwehrschild
zu verzichten dieses mit tha.d
abgekürztes System gilt als
hocheffizient und nutzt leistungsstarke
Radare um hunderte von Kilometern
entferntem militärische Bewegungen
überwachen zu können schieß aggressive
Politik bezüglich der Insel in
Südchinesischen Meer und seine Drogen
gegenüber Taiwan haben all die kleinen
Nachbarn des Landes in die schützenden
Arme von Uncle Sam getrieben es
entstehen gerade eine Vielzahl an die
chinesische Militär und
wirtschaftsbündnisse und immer mit dabei
sind die USA wir sprechen hier z.B von
orces Quad cptv oder die jüngsten
endoplässig economic Framework Peking
hat erreicht was ist eigentlich
verhindern wollte der Einfluss
Washingtons in der Region wurde gestärkt
und er führt dazu dass die
Nachbarstaaten Chinas aufrüsten um sich
vor den Drachen zu schützen wir
verlinken euch hierzu mehrere Videos zum
Beispiel die Australien im Machtkampf
gegen die Oberhand gewinnen konnte wie
sich die nach Barin Chinas gegen das
Reich der Mitte verbünden und wie die
US-Strategie im Asien Pazifikraum
aussieht die Folge der Außenpolitik
schießt ist ein isoliertes und mit
seinem Nachbarn zerstrittenes China
und das ist für das Land eine schlechte
Nachricht international erhöht sich das
Risiko von Spannungen oder eines Krieges
und auch ein China in einer Wirtschaft
oder Finanzkrise dürfte der
Weltwirtschaft insgesamt einen
Tiefschlag verpassen aber all das ist
leider die politische Realität mit der
China und der Rest der Welt noch eine
ganze Weile werden leben müssen denn es
sieht nicht danach aus dass sie so
schnell seine Macht verlieren wird im
Gegenteil das Fazit er hat einige
Erfolge erzielt von denen sich aber
einige als führungssieger erwiesen haben
andere sind nur Erfolge für ihn selbst
im Zuge seines Machtstrebens und
angesichts der vielen Misserfolge kann
man wohl sagen dass ich China unter
einem anderen Präsidenten nicht nur in
der Vergangenheit besser entwickelt
hätte auch die Zukunft Aussichten sind
Unterschied ziemlich düster zumal das
Land auch im Wettbewerb mit den USA an
Boden verliert ja so Recht will es mit
dem Status als super macht nicht klappen
aber an dieser Stelle sagt erstmal ihr
dran wie sieht ihr die Veränderung
Chinas Unterschied fällt es zurück in
eine Art erstatte Diktatur oder schafft
China doch noch die derzeitigen Krisen
zu überwinden ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch dabei gelernt habt falls ja gebt
uns bitte ein Like teils mit neuen
Freunden und vergesst nicht das Abo mit
Glöckchen um keines unserer Videos mehr
zu verpassen vergesst bitte auch nicht
das Angebot unseres heutigen Sponsors
nordpass Business zu testen mit dem
Promo Code oder über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung kannst du diese
hochwertige Sicherheitslösung für
Passwort und zugangsmanagement ganze
drei Monate lang kostenlos auf Herz und
Nieren prüfen und ich danach entscheiden
also unternimmt diesen wichtigen Schritt
für die Sicherheit eines Unternehmens
natürlich freuen uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spende von euch weiterzuführen den
Link dazu findet ihr in der
Videobeschreibung macht's gut und bis
bald
[Musik]